lunch at an eery in Suburban Manila an
endless stream of customers with
seemingly insatiable appetites for Rice
despite having to increase the price of
each Cup by as much as 50% they're still
serving an average of 25 kilos every
day I'm a huge rice eater so I like it
when there are unlimited rice
promos rice is life Filipinos like to
say but a study by the Philippine rice
Research Institute found 384,000 metric
tons of rice is wasted every year in the
country it's enough to feed 2.5 million
people for an entire year and for
Congress to act a bill that would
require restaurants to serve half cup
servings of rice is gaining ground in
the lower house that's a huge volume it
can reduce the need and then we can
balance the local produce as well as the
imported rice the Philippines is
projected to overtake China this year as
the world's largest importer of rice
supporters of the bill hope less demand
would mean less impact from fluctuations
in the global market where rice prices
are at a 15-year high so I've just
ordered a takeaway meal from a
well-known local fast food restaurant
and it comes with two pieces of fried
chicken and a full cup of rice now I can
order another cup or two but if I wanted
to eat a little bit more rice or less I
can't because there's no option for a
half
cup it's higher end and chain
restaurants like these that are more
likely to face finds if the bill is
passed this eery already offers rice in
half cup servings but its owner says the
orders are usually in addition to a full
cup of
rice bar below Al jazer
Manila make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer